hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
we're back on foreigner gate and said
everybody doing something a little bit
different we're gonna be talking about
year two and basically describing all of
what happened most of the mostly the
most notable parts of it we're not gonna
be covering the whole thing oh there's a
future video coming on that now for my
channel but from another youtuber so I'm
not gonna cover every single Looney tiny
detail all the way down to the content
of the week even if it was battle
outfits as much as I know you guys love
that stuff me too of course but I'm
gonna cover the most notable things talk
about it from each season of year 2
which is season 5 6 7 & 8 which is
marching fire and then we're gonna give
our thoughts on that and then at the end
we're gonna recap what we thought about
the whole thing and then also give our
thoughts on the future of year 3 so as
long as like the V if you do enjoy let's
get into it the first up we had season 5
the age of wolves I believe it was
called season 5 was the beginning of
year 2 and started off strong with 3
reworks and two major buffs the part of
the cast can't say conquer and mazurka
got reworks while highlander and Nobu
she got major buffs to help their
character some notable points was that
hyper armor on Berserker was there for a
couple more moves turning him into the
monster he is now
can't say received a top-heavy
unblockable pummel strike and nature's
wrath the whole mix up King as I would
call him and many other changes and
conquer got some other notable changes
like the uppercut after I blocked attack
from full block as well some other
things as well this was also the
introduction to XP tickets refined to
gear rep cata the rep cap was now level
50 instead of 40 territories on the
faction map like Mills forges and
castles updates the dual Maps to prevent
legend parry changes were also
implemented because before you we get a
guaranteed Garber a gun parry that was
not the case anymore as well as giving
new weapons and executions which is
always good to see later in the season
we got arena mode that was also added
and then the three dual maps which are
the ring sanctuary and pit sanctuary
being one of my favorite maps for duel
and the entire game very open it looks
great we also got the seasonal event
which is a poly ons legacy with the best
game-mode ever made for for on or test
your mettle where you played elimination
while fighting the characters of the
forerunner campaign mode this came with
lots of content personally one of my
favorite seasons the event test your
mettle is also one of the best in the
game this season came with lots of
content personally one of my favorite
seasons the event test your mettle is
one of the best and the game came with
lots of good changes that are still
being used today like the guard break
punishes and stuff like that
which of like I said were now
implemented with this season tester
model was such a fun mode and I wish it
would come back the rich are nice and I
personally didn't notice the effect of
them until later in the seasons but I
thought at the time the rich are pretty
good and a good addition to the game
especially because these were the first
set of reworks and now the depths were
basically saying hey we're completely
okay with revamping the old cast making
them better so that knew that we were
gonna get more in the future the weapons
and executions were great as usual I
still use the gladiator weapon set to
this day I believe it's called sanguine
iam saamne something like that one of
the greatest weapons that's gladiator
has and it's got a little it got a
little bit of flack for being a little
bit too gold and not realistic but
personally I've never had an issue with
it and I believe this is when senton has
it had his infinite combo when they gave
him the light into heavy chain although
it could be wrong I don't actually
remember what season this took place but
I just wanted to throw that out there
season six was next up with two more
reworks that being Orochi in PK
peacekeepers noticeable changes were
that her bleed cancels now always in the
top guard she has stackable bleed damage
to help her become a better hero since
she was kind of lacking dodge or GB fame
with her heavy finisher and her zone was
nerfed in terms of damage and sent with
the light and heavy openers and
finishers so a little bit of a nerf to
the damage overall but some buffs to her
bleed moves the Orochi rework is pretty
nice as well storm rushes now from all
stances the sides being pretty similar
and the top stance now being undoubtable
Riptide strike is now faster with a
different input as well as giving most
if not all of his live attacks 400 m/s
speed on top of that breach map was the
new map introduced into the game and as
usual the new weapons and executions and
the changed look system so pretty much
people could dismantle gear and free up
space in the inventory which was a huge
problem in the beginning but it was then
later fixed because of this later in the
season we got one of the worst events
the right of champions this was supposed
to talk about the lore and the story out
for honor but I feel like no one cared
and it really didn't explain much since
it basically just showed dialogue and
the challenges of some of the Warriors
and that was about it nothing too crazy
it was still a decent event with some
decent weapons and of course all the
other stuff that came with it but
overall wasn't really too impactful of
an event overall this season was cool
but not great the event like I said
before was great with the rears being
okay and could have been played off as
other changes and giving other heroes a
chance to get the rubrics early for
example I still believe that
PK's wasn't a rework I feel like they
could just play
that office changes very similar to
Highlander and no Bujji thus giving
other characters Rader law bringer
giving them a chance to get the rubes or
even pushing Valkyrie and warden to get
the rework a season earlier the
executions and the weapons were good as
usual and the change look system like I
said before really helped with the
players who needed more inventory space
the PK rework was good but she was still
a lackluster character I have no issue
fighting PKS anymore and she seemed to
be right back to where she was with just
a little bit more options birches burek
was a bit annoying because of the
constant for on a millisecond lights on
console making a huge change for players
to block and this I personally hated at
the time I still dislike it but I can
win a little bit more matches against
Orochi than before but still I really
didn't like the fact that they added
this and that this is becoming a trend I
understand why they would put 400
millisecond lights because if you make
500 very similar to gladiators chain
lights they're very easy to parry so
they obviously have to make something
fast but when half of the cast has most
of their light effects being that speed
it can be a little bit annoying to fight
against season 7 followed after that
with the warden and Valkyrie reworks
shoulder bash could now be fainted at
any time and it was much longer the
shoulder faint GB was removed and it's
now considered a hard feint instead of a
soft feint and then he also got a -
forward heavy valiant breakthrough as
well as getting a top-heavy unblockable
finisher and with that you could chain
the zone attack and the dash attack into
being openers to the heavy unblockable
which is really cool about Valkyrie got
every chain combo in existence her
shield crush cannot guarantee a light
very similar to Centurions kick second
lights were 400 milliseconds and the
sweet finisher is around 35 damage which
was a new move because of the sweep
being not too great but it was a decent
move now it's a lot more reliable if you
do happen to land the sweep because now
you can punish with some hefty damage
later we received the new event raining
inferno which made a few of the maps a
little bit more fire looking since this
was based off the volcano of the faction
map since that was a meme at the time
and I still believe is within the
community
same opinion as last time the new
weapons and new executions were great as
always I was look forward to those every
season they usually don't [ __ ] those up
which is really nice to see the event
was all right not as bad as word of
champions but not as good as a polygons
legacy it did have some decent loop the
weapons the ornaments and stuff like
that but it's more if you are enjoy the
color red and seeing as with my
character I like to rock a type of
darker
color sometimes green with gladiator the
red really didn't fit but if he didn't
like to have an all right a character or
some bright collar like that then that
was perfect for you these works are my
least favorite valkyrie didn't need a
rework at the time and that was good
that she got it but I felt other
characters needed it more than warden
like she okay and loving her but it
still helped we're gonna give him a
little bit more options this also goes
back to my last point with the other
couple seasons where if warden didn't
get that rework that would mean she go
key and law bringer could get their
rework a little bit early as to her
right now
neither of them have it and then this
would help with the other characters
getting rear excel out more faster
getting the characters back to in the
middle of the tiers and stuff like that
instead of being bottom tier but that's
just my personal opinion but besides all
that both of the characters really
aren't too hard to fight either once you
learn the patterns and the new moves
warden can be a little bit of a pain
usually with the shoulder bash but it's
not too hard and valkyries lights can
get a little bit annoying especially
with all the faints and the combo she
has but at the time are really not a
huge issue for me and then lastly we
have season 8 marching fire the biggest
season we've ever had in for honor this
came with the new faction the wolven
that came with new Xie Jang Joon tianni
Shaolin as well with Arcade Mode perks
breach mode the highly anticipated game
mode as well as the usual weapons and
executions that came along with it this
was also the introduction of new armor
and unmasked armor which we haven't
gotten a long time we haven't had new
arm where I believe until season 4 and
then the unmasked armor we've never had
before so we got to see some of the
characters faces like peacekeeper and
Nobu xi and such like that on top of
those of course the original cast got
new armor and weapons like I stated
before and the new Wulin faction also
got armor and weapons to go along with
their characters that was really cool to
look at breech maps were well designed
and looked amazing and was very hard to
play this game mode and from what I've
been told the breech game-mode is just
about as popular as the minion so I'm
glad this game mode did not fall off
like tribute and stuff so I'm very happy
for that Perks replaced gear stats in
this season as well which I still find
pretty dumb I personally think gear
stats were a lot more simple to
understand that perks and Arcade Mode
was the new PvE experience where you
could fight different missions with cool
different modifiers than being buffs and
debuffs making a challenging and a nice
refreshing combat system only issue is
that it was released with the marching
fire pass and that was the only way you
could get it which was $30 so some
people ended up not getting it and thus
not a lot of people play arcade
because the fact that they had to buy
the past so not many people did enjoy
that season eight also followed up with
a Halloween event and technically an
assassin's creed event although it is
still going on but it started near the
end of season eight so we'll still count
it both these events came with tons of
new gear weapons ornaments map changes
new event game modes and many more
personally I do enjoy the Assassin's
Creed event as much as other people may
have wanted a Christmas event
I stole have wanted a Christmas event
because I still believe ice brawler's is
one of the funnest game modes and a very
nice change to the game so I wish that
that would have came back but I'll
gladly take this as well the Halloween
event was cool it was basically like the
one from last year but just a little bit
more loot and we got to see some of the
older loot as well so I was also very
happy with this event the whole update
in general was pretty good I had a whole
trailer shown at e3 together hype it was
free on PC and it skyrocketed the player
based almost two hundred thousand
players then dipping back down to the
original which is pretty sad to see the
characters were unique and creative with
tons of cool looking armor and weapons
as well as emotes and executions unique
to them making them stand out from the
rest of the crowd in this trailer my god
man I still get chills listening to this
music every single time I hop on I've
refused to play the game until I listen
to this trailer and it's the only reason
I do not want year 3 or season n to
happen so that I can log on and hear
this every time I hop on but sadly the
characters were semi broken in the
beginning JJ had weird animations and
they were definitely buggy especially
when he was out of stamina throwing
heavies and stuff like that
Shaolin had a key stance bug at T on DS
GB vulnerability was pretty broken as
well as many other changes and there was
a few other things with new show but I
don't actually remember them personally
to me I found that this season failed
only for the small reason is that the
devs had a lot of work to do they had to
balance breach on top of the four
characters as opposed to making two
characters every season like I said
making this harder because in the past
seasons all I had to do is make sure
that the reworks are the new characters
were up to par and not too broken and
not too weak but that was only two
characters meaning that had a lot more
time to think of things whereas with
this they had to do a whole new map and
a whole new game mode as well as the
four new characters so that was a lot of
work to them which made the updates a
lot slower and then the balance us
having to stick with those for a long
time suck the law overall if I had to
rank these four seasons I would say
season 5 is easily one of the best
seasons we've ever had with for honor
lots of huge changes that are still
being implemented to this day
that being the GB changes the guard
break punishes and stuff like that the
parry changes all that stuff is still in
the game and is still very useful and
knowledgeable wonderful to know so that
was very nice they added that because
that was a very pain in the ass thing
getting parried and gettin guard broken
instantly now you have to think about
what you're gonna throw in the event
caster medal and a polygons legacy were
one of the best combos for game modes
and events ever in this game I'm very
glad that that came out and I cannot
wait until they release that again if
they release it again season 8 would
definitely come in 2nd for this it was a
whole hive trailer a lot of people saw
it especially a lot of new players even
though many of them may have may or may
not have left after the release and
stuff like that because of all the
problems with the game but it brought a
lot of new things a new game mode that
we've been wanting a whole heap of new
characters because the previous ones we
were all just getting reworked so now
we're actually getting new fresh content
arcade mode perks the whole heap of
things came in that and that season so I
was very glad that that came out
although like I said before it did have
a lot of buggy changes and a lot of
things wrong with it
I still like the trailer I still like
the season it was pretty good season 7
would be up next even though I did say
that the reworks were my least favorite
I still do believe that Valkyrie at the
time needed the rework so that was one
of the few things keeping him alive and
the fact that the reigning Inferno event
was pretty nice and they raised the
level cap to level 60 coming out with
these sulfuric sparks effect which was
really nice and I did grind it very hard
to get that and I'm very glad that I did
good self Eric sparks it's a very
nice-looking effect and lastly is season
6 my least favorite season of this whole
year we got to reworks Orochi and
peacekeeper like I stated before I still
think that these could have been played
off as changes maybe not so Orochi but
definitely peacekeeper giving other
other heroes a lot more chances at
getting rework spurrier than what we
have currently coupling that with the
event mode right of Champions which
really didn't impact gameplay at all it
wasn't that great of an event coupling
it with that and the season it really
wasn't a great season all around but of
course there was a few positives to that
that being the dismantling gear of the
change look system as well as the new
executions and weapons we got which is
the only really positive thing I found
about that season and that's gonna be my
talk about year 2 before we get into
year 3 I just want to say if I missed
anything let me know in the comments
below I'm not a mind reader
I'm not although I do keep a lot of the
logs of what has happened with 4 on
with all my videos I did actually go
back in my past videos and look at all
this I don't remember every single bit
of detail that happened so if I missed
something that you found that was
incredibly important with the season let
me know and I'll give you my thoughts on
that in the comments below and now we
have year three or the year of the
Harbinger and this is coming up very
soon at the end of January and I'm very
excited for this we afford new heroes
coming out one per season with new heavy
weapons lots of hype being built around
them with the recent leaks in the road
map and I'm very excited to play and
enjoy all of these characters and see
how they operate this season is gonna be
changing a lot
assuming we won't get fast characters
like assassins we're gonna be getting a
lot more strong boys like heavies and
vanguards so that's gonna be a nice
change of pace for the game as always
let me know your thoughts about this
video and let me know your thoughts
about Year 3 in the comments below and
what you're excited for what your
favorite season and least favorite
season of year 2 was that being 5 6 7 or
8 let me know in the comments below and
also give your thoughts on why you think
that this was the best or this was the
worst season of the game with your to
thing guys for watching the video I do
appreciate you if you made it to the end
of this video
shout out to you guys be elective if you
do enjoy subscribe if you're new I
covered the informational site a
foreigner that being balanced changes
hero updates passionates and leaks so
you want to be kept up to date with
everything that is happening with for
honor and to be caught up today with all
the news definitely subscribe to the
channel I'll keep you all up to date my
two most recent videos would be on
screen if you guys do want to check that
out with that guys hope every grace
today I think for watching the video
peace out enjoy the rest your day
[Music]
you
[Music]